les niveaux d'anxiété les niveaux des
pressions même des signes de stress post
traumatique
vingt deux ans après le début de la
pandémie il semble plus difficile que
jamais de remonter le moral des
québécois on est dans un plateau assez
négatif serait ou à peu près le quart de
la population présente des symptômes
compatibles avec soi un trouble anxieux
ou dépressifs pour chasser la grisaille
le gouvernement est venu s'inspirer ici
à lac mégantic
une communauté qui a mis de longues
années à se rétablir de la tragédie
ferroviaire qui le frappait en 2013 le
modèle n'existait pas donc on a
carrément créé le modèle mélissa
généreux était alors directrice de la
santé publique de l'estrie
elle a créé de toutes pièces un plan de
convalescence pour la population
un des souhaits c'était de mettre sur
pied une équipe de proximité qui
allaient penser autrement puis agir
autrement auprès de la population qui a
pu nani et après cela ça se mit à
débouler le des projets des initiatives
des citoyens qu'on a réussi carrément
sortir d'isolement des gens qui seraient
jamais allés à l'hôpital ou à la
clinique pour y arriver elle a mis sur
pied cette équipe un groupe composé de
travailleurs sociaux et d'intervenants
communautaire qui a des yeux et des
oreilles partout à lac mégantic le
problème dans la rue je vais voir les
gens au bord au restaurant dans les
parcs pour voir où sont les gens puis de
fil en aiguille dans le fond on ne
commence à établir des liens on se
reconnaît
peu après si ça permet aux gens des fois
devenu de poser des questions plus
pointues du genre vais choquer pour une
personne bref elle met en place un
réseau où chacun veille sur l'autre pour
que personne ne soit oublié
en temps de pandémie je pense que ça
fait vraiment grande différence
des équipes comme celle là il y en aura
partout au québec
le gouvernement investit 10 9 millions
de dollars pour en déployer une centaine
d'ici le mois d'avril
on ne fait pas du mur a menacé chaque
chaque région va développer programme à
sa façon le ministre carr mort les
appelle les éclaireurs les gens qui vont
travailler avec les gens qui sont déjà
sur le terrain pour les réseaux d
ensemble et pour faire le vide et
projets au niveau de la communauté pour
justement ce sentiment bienveillance et
août qui le mot organes à lac-mégantic
l'équipe travaille déjà sur les
activités qui seront organisées ce
printemps des occasions de prendre le
pouls de la population et de repérer la
détresse qui pourrait passer sous le
radar du goût français la musique
souvent on peut se prendre soin comme
communauté et si valérie gamache radio
canada lac mégantic